i ate my mattress
don't don't eat your mattress
they don't teach you this in school huh
the english
math history well yeah each mattress
don't eat your mattress jennifer is
addicted to eating mattress
first of all we're not making fun of
mental health we're just observing and
making
observations of course
[Music]
but my god how do you how does this
happen i'm always so fascinated how does
it start
the girl that was addicted to science
science splashing face
i'm addicted to saying a lot of y'all
pointed out as well that it's a
it's a condition called pika or
something yeah yeah here we go
uh because they're missing some sort of
nutritional value in their body
that makes you uh eat stuff like
a soap buttons clay paint as well
what because it's a deficiency of iron
and zinc
so at least there's some some sort of
logic behind it
behind it right but mattress my dude
why a mattress i haven't even started
the video and i'm already upset
usually what i do is store a lint
rolling it and sometimes hair being
there
and i had to pull it out i mean i
respect that at least
unlike going to the playgrounds and
getting sand where kids are pissed in
you know here's got someone that wants a
fine quality oh it's that foamy bit from
the mattress
i should be able to lick it like that
and nothing get caught on my tongue
he is ready to go
my name is jennifer and i'm addicted to
eating mattresses
it's a weird i already feel like i get
it that's such a soft
crunchy texture
no browse the internet safely but most
importantly freely
get past annoying country restrictions i
can definitely say that so many times
you try and watch a show and it's like
ah can't watch it there
i got you every time it's like yeah no
problem there's no bpm i already have
the subscription
it's all done i don't have to think
about it it's one of those things that's
really just
it's just good to have i recommend it if
you sign up for a two-year plan with
nordvpn
you get a huge discount plus a one month
additional for free so if you take that
offer it's really good
you sign up using the code pewdiepie
that's how you get epic access to it
you're welcome if that wasn't good
enough for you and you're not sure if a
vpn is
really worth it or not for you you can
try it risk free for 30 days
with a money back guarantee nordvpn
doesn't compromise on speed it's super
fast i use it all the time i can't tell
the difference if i'm using it or not
there's absolutely no data logging
whatsoever
so be safe out there gamers use nordvpn
i recommend it
that's nordvpn.com pewdiepie link in
description
thank you for sponsoring this video i
like my mattress plate and straight up
i know she sleeps on like three
mattresses too
gotta have a constant supply a midnight
snack
don't need to go down to the kitchen you
[Music]
fools
none of that there's like a hard texture
like
my taste buster though you know kind of
like like a guitar
when i found out that jennifer eat
mattresses i was just
bum found it i was like oh it blew my
mind that she did that
it don't look like she just matters if
you know what i'm saying all right
it's weird that i kind of get the
texture thing but the taste i don't
understand
can't you just chew on it like a chewing
gum and then spit it out
jennifer eats about a square foot of
mattresses mattress every day
square foot no how thick though
how thick we talking like an actual
mattress no
no she consumed more than eight
mattresses
eight mattresses has gone through this
woman in and out mostly in maybe i don't
know but god damn
how many calories are in a mattress i
have so many questions
mattresses are expensive too dude tiptoe
went in here
to get it the reason why i'm not eating
my own mattress
is because i ate my mattress already
i mean fair fair they really cut her out
there nice
forget hitler we need this woman as
president my god
how many calories would there be in a
mattress sized ice cream sandwich this
is this
damn that looking tasty though what is
in the mattress
polyurethane foam i wonder if this is
another
nutritional deficiency is it toxic
can cause a uh asthma lung damage
respiratory problems
damage and skin eye irritation and i
think that that's just based on
the fabric itself not actually eating it
right bro i'm looking at all this
chemistry
i just want to know can i eat it though
imagine getting home at a late at night
you jump on the bed and it's just like
boom god damn it jennifer stop eating my
mattress
while i'm not eating my own mattress
it's because i ate my mattress already
i started off with the goods the good
stuff to me is the pillow top itself
then i go down to this part
it's like a pig or an animal when you
want the nice finer parts of the
with more fat and taste and flavor how
is it it's still a mattress
what's the difference then i just start
ripping it as i go
i get to a piece
i'm done with the mattress when it
smells funny
or if i get down to where it's just
springs
i usually when i crave to eat some
mattress
it'd usually be after two o'clock i
thought eat i i'm urged i need to earn
that guy
oh my god it is a midnight snag
i mean it's got to fill you up right why
am i trying to make sense out of this i
don't know
after sex i would want some
girl ain't nobody asked
all right
some people have a smoke after segment
and the mattress right there
my dude the side effects stuff eating
mattresses
gas is really the only one you have
what it enters my body and leaves my
body it goes through my
my system and goes out
so she yeah i i assume it doesn't get
digested properly if you eat a mattress
this woman [ __ ] out eight mattresses
eight
mattresses i
that's a lot of mattresses concerned
about her health
and like her digestive system because i
have seen it
ah nah they just threw some mattress in
that toilet get out of here ain't buying
that
clean your [ __ ] toilet too my god
it's rotten there i don't see that [ __ ]
this
is all the sponges i was eating i was
like it clogged up the toilet like is it
sitting there if i was that desperate to
get it out i could take it and wash it
do everything i did to it and i could
use it again if i wanted if i was that
desperate
ain't that
did she just say it ain't that strange
okay
at five when she ate the seat of a
family car
i was sitting in the back seat and it
was like sponge down there
and i just picked it and took it and was
like
just chewed on him
couches box springs chairs
but for the last 10 years mattresses
have just been my thing
it's embarrassing i couldn't just come
out like yo i eat mattresses
can't do that it's not even all my
family knows
why not it's fascinating really
you don't say i fear that my sister
could die from this the mattress goes
down my throat
sometimes it gets stuck like i could
choke and i could die
we don't know what this mattress is
doing to her me and my son just need to
confront her today
and asked her why is she doing it
you never done that before are you
telling me you've never done that before
listen what come on we all know this
[ __ ] don't work
it needs to stop you should stop getting
mattresses you should get those
water baits right problem solved
so when you eat it are you afraid of
choking
no is that why you like all the time
yeah when i got
it shoot out of my throat like a can oh
my god i've been eating for 20 years
ain't nothing happened
i didn't know you had been doing it for
20 years
yeah oh my god she's like a cat
and you don't think that's hurting you
you don't worry about the chemicals
that's
in the match no bathroom it's for the
chemical how do you know
what mattress is made of no right but
okay
i'm not here me me me a polyurethane
foam
it's a polymer composed of organic units
joined by carbonate
urethane links while most perutrine
are thermal shedding polymers that do
not melt when heated
thermoplastic polyurethanes are also
vulnerable
oh she can just eat sponges too that's
kind of sick am i the only one finding
it a little ironic
watching these people talk about how how
do you know
i don't know i don't know if the
mattress is the issue here i'm not here
to attack you
i'm just concerned so if we go
see a doctor right and they tell you
that it's bad for you
are you going to stop why don't you
addict this or something she
know yeah exactly she knows it's bad for
her it's not going to make
any difference i hope you try
to not do it oh please
it's at the point where i don't care
yeah i gotta go
oh sh what that was so
non-confrontational i can't believe she
got upset over that
what they were so chill about it she
wants to hear
she just gets up and usually leaves we
can lead her to the right way but we
can't make her
choose the right path she has to do that
herself true
i'm going to the doctor today to get
checked out do they really need to go to
a doctor
to tell them that it's not healthy to
eat a [ __ ] mattress
is that seriously all you got tlc so how
often do you eat
mattress phone i consume it every day
in like one sitting like i would eat
like
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
always ready for a snack
oh god she got brought it to the doctor
my god so baller and then it'd be like
kind of big like that really only
symptoms that i think is connected to it
and i may be a little gassy
but then again like i'm having
sulfur burps sulfur burps yeah
like a fart in my mouth okay
sulfur birds what
in the world apparently it's a thing i
never heard it
these birds have run eggs
mattress foam is not particularly
digestible
wow some of them wow i had no idea
come on she knows all this food is not
getting down
effectively and it's fermenting and
the gas is coming back up wow i never
knew that
because it's inadjustable it could cause
a blockage and a number of potentially
deadly problems
how she's managed to do okay so far is
is a surprise it's pretty impressive i'm
not gonna lie right well the x-ray
shows no definite obstruction
but it's hard she's fine what's called
your stomach bubble
all right okay sort of that suggests
that maybe
your stomach was full um and maybe it
was full of
matcha foam mattress yeah you know the
problem you face
is you're gonna have a hole
in your intestine or a complete bowel
obstruction
doctor just give me a new just give me a
new intestine bro come on
emergency means you could die wow
okay i mean okay i don't i understand
that like this should not be surprising
to anyone right
but i understand maybe hearing it
directly from a doctor is kind of
shocking and i hope
she gets all the help she needs to
recover from this addiction
you can change this i am going to change
this
the best way to get rid of an addiction
because generally addiction comes from
some sort of anxiety and
or craving and we turn to whatever we're
used to to deal with that right at least
that's
what i i think that i have no idea
wouldn't it make sense to try to replace
matra eating mattress with something
similar that isn't so bad for you
try to think what that is what would
that be it's usually candy and stuff
like that that has that
texture i don't know bread
right
so she is doing better good happy glad
mattress foam is not particularly
digestible her wow
god damn it if you got kids
and you see them nabbing through the
seats of the car stopping
this episode was a [ __ ] roller
coaster
oh my god she took comfort food to
another level
but nice hello it's future
me i realized that video was a bit short
so i found this video french fry addict
has a meltdown over eating a carrot
devouring over 56 kilos of deep fried
french fries
each and every month she fry the fries
that are already frying that's the
equivalent of 6 000 potatoes
115 potatoes every single week
i feel like this could be marzia she's
just watching this nodding her head
she loves eating potatoes so much
amber eats french fries breakfast lunch
and dinner
but amber cannot just eat any french
fries yeah smell
color and texture are also important
i guess you know it comes with a
goddamnit a lot of the times fries will
have oh she's picking out the
wow and like this that is definitely
something that i cannot eat so i will
take
that and stick it underneath the napkin
and then eat the rest of the fry i will
feel even a little euphoric after eating
fries
i'm not sure what it is about them that
makes them so good
but the fat
the fat makes them good
i mean i guess it's weird commenting
about someone's appearance but she
doesn't look
that big is that yeah i like the way
for someone that only use french fries i
think that you're only reaching for
those french fries
i feel that there is something beyond
oh i don't want to eat that i mean
that's definitely not it because i do
want to eat it and there are foods that
i have sat down and have tried
what happens i throw it up okay so i'm
hearing you do want to try to eat
healthy
yes i've tried but you can't i can't i
definitely am leaning more towards
the fact that it's it's medical because
i know that i'm what i'm doing is not a
choice
i mean even just one new food can open
up a whole lot of
options for me even one good so before
amber tackles it so she's willing to try
something else
start with tastes and also textures
that you already like and then we change
one thing at a time
this is going to teach your brain that
you can't eat this
i am very he's pretty smart and even
though french fries are a safe food
changing their color makes me feel
uneasy
i would like for you to she's like boy
swimish how
dare you do this to the french french i
feel like this is not a baby step
whoa this is not where i would have
chosen to start that seems like a
baby step to me where else would you go
with it what
the therapist is smart the rainbow fries
was genius i thought so too she's not
into it though so
oh wow i wanted it over with i
just wanted to be done with the rainbow
fries
how you feeling right now
i'm trying to figure out how i'm going
to do this every time you try something
new
you are going to be one step closer to
having the life that you want
yeah yuck
there was a real good job duck face when
you put that in your mouth
it wasn't pleasant but it also wasn't
extremely
unpleasant right hey the fact that
that's
smart i'm more impressed by the
therapist than anything i i
i feel like you want to just laugh out
oh so silly and she can't eat
but she obviously has a condition so
it's it's not that funny
it's more bizarre this is really
interesting was able to take a bite
to me is a success i just want amber to
have a bite
to have the experience and to say did i
die no
and if not then i'm okay building on her
progress dr dao now moves on to an even
more unnatural color she's so disgusted
it looks like a dead blue finger the
average person may say
eating a blue french fry is no big deal
you know why is she crying all this
well you have to understand that for
amber emotionally it's like jumping out
of an airplane
oh wow
here i want to give you a huge
amount of credit for what you just did i
knew
that any step that would take is going
to
provoke some fear and amber it's really
interesting
because yeah this is french fries so
it's kind of goofy
but this is it i mean i assume this is a
human's work you know you
you build a habit of doing the exact
same thing if she's only eaten french
fries
for however long 26 years
anything out of that is gonna feel like
a jumping off a cliff it's a good
reminder of why you should always push
yourself if you feel uncomfortable
because any time you back down from
something you weren't sure about doing
obviously there's limits to it obviously
but
we we know most of the time when there's
something that we think we should do but
we don't want to do it because we're a
little scared right
that thing the next time you're faced
with it is going to become even scarier
as opposed to just doing it because then
next time that thing is will not be half
as scary as it was the first time
and that just seems like what the human
mind how we uh
see things i don't know i'm not a
[ __ ] psychiatrist but
it's interesting and we see it here with
the french fries i think it's the fact
that she was able to take this step
says that she can indeed make changes to
her diet and her life
this was hard for you and you did it
[Music]
after a day of intense therapy amber has
made it it is kind of it is a little
funny though
it's her crying that makes it funny
first difficult step in treating the
psychological fear of new foods
now dr dao and jj want to see if she can
take an even bigger leap
and try a new taste amber's used to
eating
deep fried
thought the easiest step for her to make
was to stay within the deep fried
and then try new tastes in that fashion
jj orders a variety of different
vegetables ranging from the familiar
like potato
to the unfamiliar such as carrots
asparagus and mushroom
bro they don't even look good you gotta
cook them properly
these are literally just boiled and
nothing else right where do you want to
start shall we start easy
um all right okay jj wanted me to try
they're frying them okay that makes
sense it was apprehensive on so many
levels
it smells like a potato in canola oil no
weather smells like a french fry
but we have something in the ballpark of
familiar right yeah
yeah oh geez
[Music]
see i don't think this is i don't think
this is food i don't think it's anything
you know logically gonna kill you
no but i mean eating dirt won't kill me
it doesn't mean it's a good idea
she uses so much all or nothing thinking
she uses a lot of
catastrophic thinking yeah i want amber
to understand that there is some gray
area here
not everything has to be pleasant to her
but it doesn't have to be all bad
but you could eat this and keep it in
your mouth right probably
well in that case bon appetit
to keep moving forward jj suggests
another mild tasting
that's not gonna fly is that how it's
supposed to look
i've never had a deep fried carrot
before trying new things
if it was such a big deal to just do a
different color
of the same food i feel like this is it
this is a bit
of a big leap to jump to vegetables
right
[Music]
you tried yeah she tried
and you're okay so what did you teach
yourself today amber i didn't teach
myself anything
you look really angry at us right now
i'm angry because
what did you know what do you want me to
do right here i'm i'm trying
but when i you know i i keep getting
pushed a little pushed a little pushed a
little
and that's all you had to do okay do you
get that you did exactly
what you could do and that's all we
expected of you our intention is not to
get you mad
it is to help you to move forward i want
to get the hell out of here
i clicked on this thing and it was funny
but it's just interesting and
just kind of sad sorry i threw you guys
in with a different vibe here
the amount of patience these people have
is amazing yeah i mean
she's clearly the kind of person that if
you push
she's just gonna break and never try it
again right
i think that's how this started to begin
with i don't understand how human grows
to become like this
i it's weird that i perfectly understand
it i think at least
i used to hate vegetables and in my mind
i
i mean this is obviously not the same
but in your in my mind it was so much
worse than it
really is and then you try it and you
realize oh actually it's not that bad
yeah it's how it works right i get it
woman eats 100 square meters of drywall
oh my god
i'm addicted to eating dry wall god damn
it
god damn it i
am it is that thing again right pica
appetite for substances that are largely
non-nutritive
it can be caused by a deficiency of iron
zinc
nicole has been addicted to eating
drywall for over seven years
it started innocently with a bite of
chalk
could happen to anyone at any point
that's what's so baffling about this
just one day i decided to eat chalk and
seven years later i ate 100 square
meters of drywall
drywall because drywall tastes better
than it tastes
it tastes better now ingests drywall
up to six times a day i love the
smell of drywall the texture of it the
taste
i love everything about tribal and i'll
probably eat about
this much a day damn
damn i
get drywall wherever i can find it my
house
yeah well your house would be a fair
start i think
my friend's house my friend sometimes my
grandmother house
ah this is the hole in my water
created by she created a hole in the
wall oh no
you can make drywall you don't have to
eat your own house
picking and i've been picking at it for
like
two see i understand having an addiction
but i don't understand why you got to
eat your own house i take a piece like
this and i take it and i
break it it does have a satisfying snap
to it i will give her that
[Music]
different kind of drywall some are
thicker than others some
they don't taste the same for instance
the green dry wall over there
that one has a nasty taste over there
and this one just has like
a fresher taste to me see this i can
respect you know when they have a fine
taste of something
that drywall over there that's present
drywall i would not go
near that this is to coop the cream
all right well i'm gonna do a brief exam
if that's okay yo why is the tychum
titan in the back
that's awesome she really took i'm so
hungry i could eat a house literally
poisonous to humans and even cause
cancer later on
that's really bad yeah yeah the good
news is you're not
it's always like this they know it's bad
but as soon as they hear from a doctor
it's like
i get that i kind of get them but at the
same time like what
this is killing me what it was a real
wake-up call
i hope uh for all the best for nicole
hope she recovers from her addiction
that's it from my stranger obsession of
diction
i don't know how i feel about this i i'm
kind of like
like the concept is humorous but then
you see the individual and it's like
this is actually not that funny i don't
know what do you guys think
let me know see you tomorrow bye bye oh
remember to subscribe every subscriber i
get i get one more subscriber so that's
really really cool
epic